MIKE FAIRHURST: Hi, everyone.
I'm Mike Fairhurst.
I've been working for a little
over a year on a analysis
plugin for AngularDart.
Let's see.
And next-- there we go.
So the analysis plugin is a
plugin to the Dart analysis
server, which is a common
back end for all of the IDEs
that are supported by the
Dart team and the community.
So by plugging into
the analysis server,
we're able to expose some of the
same language features, right
in the IDE of your choice.
This can include autocompletion
and things like that.
The API that we're using is--
we're the first user, so the API
may be a little bit unstable.
But we are excited for other
potential uses of it as well.
For our plugin, we are
fully open sourced.
And so we're hoping that
people will see this demo,
they will want to give it a
try, and give us feedback.
Because we think it's
really, really great,
and so we're hoping we can make
it part of the core AngularDart
offering.
So yes, it's static analysis,
so it catches your errors.
But as a creator, I think it
is a little bit more than that.
So it can actually serve as
a form of documentation which
is right at your fingertips.
So autocompletion is
like doing a Control F,
except it's
context-aware, right?
And more than simple lookups,
if we talk semantics,
Angular templates have
some interesting rules
you might not be aware of,
maybe you've never bumped into.
This plugin's gonna
know all them.
Its really hard to document
some of that behavior,
so instead we can have it
right at your fingertips.
If you trip one of
these corner cases,
then it's going to
alert you right away.
And we're hoping
that it gives you
actionable feedback, or
at least googleable terms,
so that you don't have
to go to Stack Overflow.
And then, luckily,
AngularDart is
a very, very static
framework, much more static
than Angular JS.
So we think that we can
catch a lot of your issues,
though we do avoid
dependency injection.
Because yeah, someone once
proved that it was NP-hard,
so we didn't touch that.
So I did have
technical problems,
but I have slides here.
That's what you get for
using Linux on a laptop.
So this is basically just the
Angular Quickstart Project.
I've made some additions
to break things
so we can see how it
works in an invalid app.
You can see all
of the errors are
highlighted in red, which
is my little template
on the right side.
So we use Dart because we
want static type checking
when it's available.
So just the ability to find
this length misspelling,
it's underlined in red,
you can see it instantly--
super, super easy to fix.
But it can catch more
complicated errors too.
So it says here, you know, "that
bound [INAUDIBLE] keyrelease
does not exist on
any directives."
So the immediate question
is, what does exist?
And maybe we would go to MDN.
Maybe we would go to ask
our coworker, look at code
we've written before.
Well, now you can
just autocomplete.
So you can instantly see just--
[APPLAUSE]
So you can instantly see that
it's key up, not keyrelease,
and instantly fix it.
Additionally, once you have
this event configured correctly,
it's going to catch something
which I bet money none of you
caught when I showed
the earlier slides.
So the Angular plugin is
going to be smarter than you.
It catches a mismatch in the
event variable type itself,
something you never
write down yourself.
But it's going to track
that through the program
and say, your component defined
close window with a mouse
event, but key up
was a keyboard event.
You no longer have to run your
tests to find the failure.
It's right there.
It also catches
missing directives.
A really, really critical thing
that happens all the time,
people put in a behavior that
just doesn't do anything.
Because you didn't
include the directive.
And now it's super,
super easy to fix.
And then many
AngularDart users here
probably went quite
a while before ever
learning about transclusions.
So transclusions are defined
by this template down here.
So it's actually going to be
in the template of a component
that you're using in your own
template of your own component.
And it's kind of
configured in a way
that's great for writing a
component, but nothing else.
You are always going
to be really lucky
if someone documents the
way that this stuff works.
And now you don't have to worry
about whether you're lucky
or not.
Because you can
just autocomplete,
and the plugin itself
is going to know
you're inside of a dialogue.
It's going to know what
transclusion selectors are
available, and it's
going to generate a HTML
tags-- complete with
properties, in this case, which
are required in order to
get you working productively
right away.
Yeah, so hopefully
everyone tries it out.
Anyone who's using
AngularDart, you just
have to add these four lines
to your analysis options.
Restart your analysis server
and give it a few minutes.
It's going to download
and it's going
to use pub [? resolve ?]
dependencies and stuff
like that.
But yeah, we're on GitHub.
So we hope you like it, and if
not, definitely let us know.
File bugs and questions,
and you can email me.
And then, best of
all, while I'm here,
take some time, if you can, to
fire this up on your project.
Some of its errors
may be confusing.
I would love to help
you out with it,
if you bring a laptop over, and
see what it catches for you,
and go from there.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]